joe rogan got in trouble this week uh
for
some offensive comments that he made on
his podcast and i'll play the clip this
is a clip it went viral
people were upset about it and uh it's
kind of a where's waldo type of thing
can you spot
the offensive moment in what he says
here it's not it's not it's not as easy
as you might think let's listen
you can never be woke enough that's the
problem it keeps going it keeps going
further and further and further down the
line and if you get
to the point where you capitulate where
you
agree to all these demands it will
eventually get to
straight white men are not a lot of talk
right because it's your privilege to
express yourself when
other people of color have been silenced
throughout history it will be
you're not allowed to go outside because
so many people were imprisoned for so
many years i mean i'm not joking no i
know i know it really will get there
it's that crazy you know we just got to
be nice to each other man
and there's a lot of people that are
taking advantage
of this weirdness in our culture and
then that becomes their thing
their thing is calling people out for
their privilege calling people out for
their position
you know so crazy times
it's so easy it almost takes the fun out
of it
in a way it's so easy to be
controversial
it's so easy to upset people to be
provocative
you don't even have to try i wish you
did have to try
i'm accused of being a provocateur
contrarian i'm just trying to upset
people
i wouldn't put it past me to do that
okay
because i do enjoy it when a bunch of
morons are upset
i i do enjoy that i do enjoy that
spectacle and when they're all screaming
at me i think it's hilarious
but um but i don't know i don't have to
try to provoke
i'm really because i i can simply
express really common sense
viewpoints that i of course totally
believe
and get that kind of reaction so that's
what you just heard there from
joe rogan joe rogan provocateur what did
he
nothing about that was was surprising or
even arguable
yeah there's an anti-white male
sentiment out there of course there is
it's impossible to not notice it it's
everywhere
in fact if i were to take issue with
anything joe rogan said
it's the part where he said we're
getting to the point where
if you're a white male you're not
supposed to talk in fact in many corners
of society
and according to a lot of people we're
already at that point
there are a lot of people who think that
joe rogan should stop talking because
he's a he's a white male
and is privileged and doesn't understand
the lived experience of oppressed people
or whatever nonsense
so we are already at that point
for a lot of for a lot of people who
think that uh if you're a white male you
should just stop talking
all you have to do is listen to them and
they'll tell you they've told me
i hear that all the time that is one of
the most common rebuttals
to my completely common sense
non-surprising
ideas and positions one of the most
common rebuttals is you're well you're a
white male
which isn't a rebuttal at all obviously
but it's simply to to
to point out my sex and race
is supposed to be enough to shut down
the argument
so yes we are at that point listen hit
that subscribe button
right now do it right now i thank you
for your compliance
it is somewhat appreciated